[Music]
so Angela
but I shall open
that the whole
lady so high level feed the power
what then
[Music]
okay so basically we have a I think the
personal Salim who said that and this
one the beautiful things that I love
about Islam is that in Islam we believe
that for example if I intend to let's
say punch him yeah I don't think the and
I don't have a things about sighs no no
no trust me trust me it's not about
sighs you know trust me yeah I've seen
them gay you only take a number a little
- yeah so basically if I intend and say
look I'm going to punch a job yeah if I
do it yeah and I'm still alive if I do
it it's a sin if I intend to do it but I
don't do it if I intend to do it and I
don't do it I get a reward did you
understand that I'll repeat it I'm
intending to punch him I get a sin
I intend to punch him but I don't do it
I get a reward yes if I intend to say
intent to say okay I'm gonna give him
who dies first here
okay I'll give him I intend to
but I don't do it I get a reward if I do
do it don't push your way yeah I get
tenfold
like more rewards yeah and this is
beautiful because what it shows is that
when you have these urges sister are you
okay when you have these urges system
what it is is that you're seen I have
these urges but for the sake of Allah
and my love for my Lord I'm not gonna do
it you can't reward this is a form of
another because you're abstaining from
me because you say I want to please my
lord but you actually get rewarded for
that and that's what's really beautiful
about Islam I would personally say
I'll just touch one I don't have a mic
can hear me there let me turn it off so
even when it's one it annoys me yeah so
basically the way we can answer that is
now we hate the sin but not the sinner
yeah so there are people who have these
urges yeah now in Islam
all of you guys know the surah fatiha
yeah should we just quickly recite
together yes when I say one two three
yeah bismillah r-rahman r-rahim al-hamdu
lillahi rabbil aalameen arrahmani
arraheem Maliki o McBean Yaka na'budu wa
iyyaka nastain dina sirat al-mustaqim
sirata al-ladhina and EMTALA him why L
must obey alayhim wala Dalene now we
recite this on a daily basis here
yokka na'budu wa iyyaka nastain you
alone we worship and you alone we ask
for help now how does this connect to
this yeah even with the Shahada what you
say when you testify there is nothing
worthy of worship except this negation
and affirmation yeah except allah
subhanho wa taala as muslims our main
focus is to heat yeah it's the oneness
of allah that we affirm and we worship
Allah and Allah alone yeah and we recite
this in our surah fatiha in and out yes
okay now all of us have desires I came
to Islam 2012 23rd of December yeah I
lived a life of sin be a partying
whatever it may be
yeah and I to be honest with you should
I tell you something one of the things
that delayed me in accepting Islam even
though I knew it was the truth was my
desires now how does this relate to this
here we all have desires there are men
out there who want to go and sleep
around with
anything that moves yeah yes I'm sorry
there are men out there that they allow
that yeah there's a man you might heard
of an article who married a piano yeah
he actually married a piano yes his wife
is a piano and yeah you think I'm joking
about your key oh yeah okay and he seems
quite happy yeah
feminist you know I'm not saying you
know yeah because maybe the piano don't
speak back anyways I'm joking
so basically we have these desires yeah
I lost font Allah says in the Quran that
you think that you're gonna say I
believe and not be tested yeah you're
gonna have these desires yeah but
submitting your will to Allah what that
means is this when I came to Islam I
said look this is what I want to do ABCD
etc etc etc yeah then I have the truth I
believe this is the truth this I believe
Allah is my Lord yeah I have a choice to
make either follow my desires and this
is a message to our sisters and our
brothers user Muslims and those in
humanity who are not Muslim what we're
seeing too is this this is the essence
of Islam and this is my message to you
if you're watching this yet I'll make it
very clear to you we don't hate you
yeah we don't say ok you know when I see
a gay person no it's not like that what
it is is that we believe that we should
control those desires yes
so a man who wants to go and sleep
around his controllers desires why for
the sake of allah subhanho wa taala
he's saying my lord you alone a worship
we worship I worship and you don't ask
for help so what it is is you're gonna
have these desires as a Muslim if you're
getting this desires or non-muslim what
we see is when we speak to them instead
of talking about these issues
ok were you born like this did this did
this come later in your life or whatever
it may be what we're seeing is we bring
them back without heat because once they
understand the connection and the love
that you have with your Creator that's a
different kind of relationship nobody
can understand that unless is in the
Quran only in the remembrance of Lord do
your heart find peace and if you forget
my remembrance you'd have a depressed
life what that means is we believe in
something called the fitrah yep that we
are all programmed that we would only
find happens with the permission with
the remembrance of Allah the heart would
ask for
money cars girls this that you will feed
it the heart would reject it because the
heart thing that's not what I need
that's why you see people who are
chasing happiness and be rich people
famous people someone told me you saw
Brad P in Hollywood we're gonna go
Hollywood and he was depressed he broke
up from Angelina Jolie
yeah I don't keep up today but that's
what I heard yeah he was depressed why
because when you attach your heart to
something other than Allah
you would never be happy because your
happiness was based on what if I based
my happiness on this pen yeah okay once
this pen leaves me my happiness goes
with it if I attach my heart to a female
once that female goes I'm gonna be
depressed again but when you attach your
heart to your Lord he would never leave
you
so what we're saying to our friends who
may have these tendencies is that look
it's a way of dealing with it by seeing
that when you understand your relation
with your Lord you're gonna say look
have these tendencies and get these
force I have these urges and we have
believe me we have Muslims in Islam they
are major sins yeah [ __ ] bida yeah big
eyes innovation yeah and some people
like to use it be there better be that
everyone's innovator yeah some people
have that sadly major sin yeah major sin
some say major sin is above vida etc etc
this category yeah being homosexual acts
in a punto upon it is a sinister
medicine in our religion it is having
those thoughts and not acted upon it is
not yeah and there are Muslims who are
out there and by the way if you have
these changes and even if you acting
upon them you're committing a major sin
but that does not negate the fact that
you cannot be a Muslim you are a Muslim
but you're sinning just the way a man
who goes and sleeps around
yeah and doesn't give the rights of his
wife he's committing a major sin so what
would you saying is that in a nutshell
is that once you have a conditional de
Lord you're saying I have these
tendencies this is what I want to do but
my love for my lord is so great and
beyond that yeah that I'm going to stay
away from that and hopefully in the hair
after my lord will inshallah give reward
me this life is a test that's all we're
asking now somebody can come and say
look I don't want you you have every
right you if you say I don't want you
and I want to practice it you have every
right to
my job he jobs job our team job is our
job is to convey the message did I just
what I just told you I've conveyed it to
you you can speak yes you will testify
in front of our lab convey this to you
my job is done you want to take it not
take it to do two backflips and jump
through the window that's up to you
but my job is done it's done so
inshallah that would answer your
question and we need like I said when
again these tendencies wherever it may
be you're overcoming it for the sake of
Allah this is the fundamental thing
within our religion and that's what
we're asking people to do whatever
desires it might be most homosexuality
whatever it may be left want to kill
somebody etc stop those young need those
things for the sake of Allah but a
person has every right to say nope
I want you that's your choice I would
answer like that sister has it answered
your question
[Music]
as far as I know from my little
knowledge adapt and touch upon that as
well is that it is forbidden not like
Allah has mentioned that he has
destroyed nations before because of this
specific sin and even different actually
is quite unique because in different
destructions that Allah has gave up on
and Allah says he does not destroy a
nation until he sent a messenger so that
some of them most of the times it was
that they will associate in partners to
God but funnily enough interestingly
enough with this specific issue is
arriving correct me at the time of
normalizer oh look it was not looked
good early Salam
that that is not mentioned much but it's
the act of the homosexuality that I've
actually mentioned why God did that but
besides that it's just that from what I
know that was the reason and it's it's a
sin it's it's it's Janna in a nutshell
it's a sin that we should stay away from
and that's if there's anything you want
I don't